wir schauen auf den nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt es geht um den
bericht des untersuchungsausschusses
breitscheidplatz der ist ja 20 18
eingesetzte geworden und hintergrund ist
der anschlag an eben diesem anschlag auf
dem breitscheidplatz und dazu jetzt
erstmal ein paar anmerkungen des
bundestags präsidenten zuvor einen
polnischen lastwagenfahrer ums leben
gebracht hatte um dessen fahrzeug zu
einem mordwerkzeug zu machen
er verletzte weitere 170 menschen einige
von ihnen schwer
der sie unter bleibenden schäden leiden
angehörige der opfer des attentats vom
breitscheidplatz sind heute auf der
tribüne anwesend ich begrüße sie ebenso
mit zahlreiche betroffene die bei diesem
terroranschlag verletzt worden
sie sind zum teil von weit her angereist
und wir werden nachher die gelegenheit
zu einem persönlichen austausch haben
ich spreche ihnen und ihren familien und
auch den heute nicht anwesenden
hinterbliebenen und verzehrten im namen
des ganzen deutschen bundestags unser
tief empfundenes mitgefühl aus
das attentat auf den weihnachtsmarkt am
breitscheidplatz hat sich in unser
gedächtnis eingegraben
zum einen weil so viele unschuldige
menschen ihr leben verloren haben so
viele verletzt oder traumatisiert worden
und zum anderen weil die absicht so
anmaßend war der attentäter wollte
unsere art in freiheit zu leben
zerstören
er wollte unfrieden stiften kurz vor
weihnachten uns ist der terrorakt auch
im gedächtnis weil noch viele fragen
aufgeworfen hat und die schmerzlichste
dieser fragen lautet warum ist es damals
nicht gelungen den anschlag zu
verhindern
obwohl der täter den sicherheitsbehörden
als gefährlich bekannt war
der untersuchungsausschuss zum attentat
auf dem breitscheidplatz hat am montag
sein bericht vorgelegt und der ist
gegenstand der debatte für die wir jetzt
seine dauer von 60 minuten beschlossen
haben und die ich hiermit eröffnet das
erste redner in der debatte ist der
vorsitzende des untersuchungsausschusses
der kollege klaus dieter gröhler cdu csu
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
viereinhalb jahre nach dem
folgenschwersten dschihadistischen
anschlag auf deutschem boden
der erste untersuchungsausschuss dieser
wahlperiode 40 monate nach beginn seiner
arbeit am jetzt montag ihnen herr
präsident sie erwähnten es eben den
bericht über seine arbeit übergeben
heute diskutieren wir diesen 1873 seiten
starken abschlussbericht hier im plenum
als vorsitzender des
untersuchungsausschusses noch öfter aber
als abgeordneter des berliner
wahlkreises in dem dieser mörderischen
anschlag stattgefunden hat bin ich
gefragt worden warum wir das alles
überhaupt noch aufarbeiten
oftmals wurde auch gesagt dass wir das
leid ohnehin nicht ungeschehen machen
können das stimmt natürlich
und dennoch gab es zwölf besondere
gründe für unser aktive schuss
aufarbeiten
ich erinnere an anna und georgi batra
toni sebastian berlin
na das schisma fabrizio di lorenzo daher
jacken christoph herrlich klaus jakob
angelika klösters dorit krebs lubahn und
peter völker an dieser stelle darf ich
sehr herzlich die opfer hinterbliebenen
und betroffenen des attentats hier heute
begrüßen wir alle sind dankbar dass sie
die einladung unseres bundestags
präsidentin angenommen habe
jetzt hier die debatte im parlament
verfolgen und wir uns im anschluss noch
austauschen können
ich darf aber auch an die vielen
menschen erinnern die an jedem abend
mitten in der berliner city verletzt
wurden körperlich oder seelisch als ob
zwei augenzeugen oder helfer viele von
ihnen trank bis heute nennt folgende und
ausdrücklich möchte ich die gelegenheit
nutzen jenen die am 19 dezember hilfe
geleistet haben ob im dienst oder
ehrenamtlich sehr herzlich zu danken
[Applaus]
die arbeit des ausschusses konnte und
kann sicherlich trösten und auch keine
wunden heilen
wir haben aber versucht auf quälende
fragen antworten zu finden
besonders auf die frage wie es passieren
konnte dass ein polizeibekannter
krimineller und gefährde der kein
aufenthaltsrecht im schengen-raum hatte
diesen anschlag
dennoch verfügen konnte wir haben 132
sitzungen durchgeführt 147 zeuginnen und
zeugen 462 stunden lang vernommen
tausende aktenordner wurden von bundes-
und landesbehörden vorgelegt und vom
ausschuss ausgewertet der bundestag hat
sogar selbst gutachter und
sachverständige beauftragt unter anderem
um die spurenlage zu analysieren
trotz allen aufwandes sind aber einige
fragen ohne antworten geblieben so
konnten wir nicht aufklären auf welchem
weg der mörder berlin verlassen hat wer
ihm vielleicht geholfen oder ihn
angestiftet hat wir wissen bis heute
nicht wie er eine schusswaffe gelangte
und ob er auf seiner flucht nach italien
unterstützer traf was wir aber wissen
ist dass es vor nach dem attentat
individuelle und organisatorische fehler
und fehleinschätzungen gegeben hat
versäumnisse strukturelle und personelle
probleme und auch mangelnde
kommunikation zwischen behörden auf der
bundes- und auf der länder dem namen
keine dieser fehler und mängel war für
sich allein kausal für den anschlag
aber alle zusammen waren fatal denn
eigentlich hätte der attentäter vor dem
anschlag in haft genommen und seine
abschiebung konsequent betrieben werden
müssen da bekomme ich für mich zu dem
traurigen ergeben
dass diese mörderische tat hätte
verhindert werden können
auch der anschließende umgang
staatlicher stellen mit opfern und ihren
angehörigen hat zurecht befremden
ausgelöst
wir mussten aber auch feststellen dass
es vor dem anschlag auch auf seiten der
gesetzgebung versäumnisse gegeben hatte
an dieser stelle möchte ich mich bei den
opfern und hinterbliebenen
stellvertretend herzlich um verzeihung
für dieses versäumnis bitten
dieser anschlag hat bei vielen kollegen
zur intensiven überprüfung der
gesetzlichen ausgestaltung unserer
sicherheitsagentur und der betreuung und
entschädigung von opfern und
hinterbliebenen geführt meine beiden
unions kollegen dr volker ullrich und
alexander throm werden gleichung
einzelnen die inzwischen auf den weg
gebrachten gesetzesänderungen die
verbesserungen bei der ausstattung
unserer sicherheitsbehörden und das was
wir von der cdu csu an weiteren stünden
für erforderlich halten darstellen ein
parlamentarischer untersuchungsausschuss
meine damen und herren hat aber nicht
nur die aufgabe selbst zu hinterfragen
ausleuchten vielmehr dient seine arbeit
auch dazu dass die behörden und die
ministerien ihr eigenes handeln kritisch
aufarbeiten
wir haben im ausschuss zeugen erlebt
denen jede selbstreflektion vierte wir
haben andere erlebt die teils sehr
emotional um verzeihung gebeten haben
und die diesen anschlag auch als
persönlichen misserfolg ihrer arbeit
betrachtet haben und dass sich an dieser
stelle auch deutlich sagen viele andere
anschläge konnten den letzten jahren in
unserem land rechtzeitig verhindert
werden dafür sind wir dankbar das
sollten wir auch im lichte dieses
berichts nicht vergessen wir alle wären
aber sicherlich froh gewesen wenn auch
die morde auf unserem weihnachtsmarkt
hätten verhindert werden können
aber vielleicht kann die arbeit unseres
ausschusses dazu dienen dass sich
vergleichbares nicht wiederholt
sicherlich hat aber unsere arbeit und
auch die der beiden
untersuchungsausschüsse im lande berlin
und in nordrhein westfalen gezeigt dass
der demokratische und föderale
hat in der lage ist fehler aufzutreten
versäumnisse einzugestehen verantwortung
zu übernehmen und korrekturen
einzuleiten bei uns werden die dinge
eben nicht unter den teppich gekehrt
sondern transparent und nachprüfbar
aufgearbeitet als ausdruck
parlamentarischer kontrolle der
exekutive
das ist eine der stärken unserer
freiheitlich parlamenten dieses
freiheitsrecht parlamentarischen systems
die wir jederzeit verteidigen müssen und
auf die wir stolz sein dürfen
abschließen meine damen und herren
möchte ich mich bedanken
alle fraktionen im ausschuss haben mit
engagement in vom plenum einstimmig
gefasst untersuchungsauftrag bearbeitet
über parteigrenzen hinweg stand das
interesse an der aufklärung der
beantwortung der fragen ich darf
insbesondere mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern der fraktionen danken die
sich durch die ausgelieferten akten und
protokolle der vernehmungen gearbeitet
haben ohne sie hätten wir abgeordnete
nicht unseren auftrag erfüllen können
mein dank gilt aber besonders auch dem
ausschuss sekretariat sie haben mehr als
vorsitzendem hervorragend zur seite
gestanden nicht vergessen möchte ich
auch den stenografischen dienst der auch
bei unseren teils 12 in ihren sitzungen
bis mitternacht die protokolle geführt
hat die bundestagsverwaltung und die
polizei des bundestages die wir bei der
vernehmung einiger zeugen aus dem umfeld
des mörders gut gebrauchen konnten wir
sollten aber auch die vertreter der
behörden des bundes und der länder nicht
vergessen den im ausschuss für verfügung
standen und die zahlreichen mitarbeitern
mitarbeiter die akb ausgesucht haben um
zusammen gestellt haben damit wir unsere
arbeit machen konnten mein dank galt
abschließend auch der presse die
regelmäßig über unsere ausschussarbeit
errichtet hat und den besucherinnen und
besuchern die fortdauernd die sektion
des ausschusses begleitet haben
gestatten sie mir noch ein persönliches
wort ich selbst wäre fast am 19 dezember
20 16 zu diesem weihnachtsmarkt gefahr
ich habe mich mit meinem sohn in der 2
entschieden dass wir es einen tag später
machen und wir sind an dem abend nach
potsdam gefahren
auf dem rückweg haben wir von diesem
anschlag
und ich war am 20 dezember dann selbst
auf dem breitscheidplatz und aber heute
noch die beklemmende stille und
mittelbaren kurfürstendamm im ohr
eine situation die ich bis dahin nicht
kannte und auch aus diesem grund hoffe
ich meine damen und herren das der
deutsche bundestag nie wieder wegen
eines vergleichbaren vorgang sun
untersuchungsausschuss einsetzen muss
herzlichen dank die sehr persönliche
worte am ende von klaus dieter gröhler
dem vorsitzenden des ersten
untersuchungsausschusses des
untersuchungsausschusses zum
terroranschlag auf dem breitscheidplatz
am 19 dezember 2016 erster
untersuchungsausschuss deshalb weil er
als erster eingesetzt worden ist in
dieser jetzt auslaufenden
legislaturperiode stefan kreuzer war in
diesem ausschuss obmann für die afg
fraktion und er ist der nächste redner
hier eher präsident meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe gäste
insbesondere persönlich betroffen
wir haben einen untersuchungsausschuss
eingesetzt und wenn wir auf den anfang
der 19 wahlperiode zurückschauen müssen
wir gucken was der
untersuchungsausschuss sein sollte
meine fraktion wollte neben der
beschränkung auf das geschehen um das
attentat außerdem den fokus drehen auf
die asyl- und migrationspolitik die
kosten der migrationspolitik die
fragwürdigen grenzöffnung 2015 und den
islamismus und insbesondere islamischen
terrorismus
all das haben wir als antrag nicht
durchbekommen den untersuchungsauftrag
haben die etwas enger gefasst andere
anträge haben wir auch nicht
durchbekommen unter anderem hatten wir
als einzige fraktion beantragt die
bundeskanzlerin frau dr angela merkel in
den zeugenstand zu rufen das wurde von
allen anderen fraktionen abgelehnt
es hat fast ein jahr gedauert bis die
bundeskanzlerin zu einer gedenkfeier zu
bewegen war und sie gab ein versprechen
es werde alles unternommen werden um
dieses attentat aufzuklären
ich finde es beschämend dass sie bei
dieser historischen debatte heute durch
abwesenheit glänzt
ob hier versprechen wohin herr kollege
tradition doch helfen um keinen falschen
eindruck zu erwecken die fraktion sind
davon unterrichtet dass die
bundeskanzlerin nach ihrer erklärungs
erklärung und der debatte zum
europäischen rat berlin verlassen musste
um an eben diesem europäischen rat
teilzunehmen
also bitte ich bitte sie einfach in der
debatte des zu berücksichtigen
ich finde es trotzdem bedauerlich dass
sie bei dieser debatte nicht da ist und
herr präsident ich hoffe sind nur in
meiner rede zeit etwas nachsichtig weil
die uhr lief gerade weiter schauen wir
auf die arbeit im untersuchungsausschuss
der untersuchungsausschuss hatte es
nicht immer leicht hatte es mit
widerständen zu tun insbesondere
konsultationen mit ausländischen
nachrichtendiensten waren hinderlich
ermittlungs vorbehalte methoden schutz
interventionen durch die bundesregierung
insbesondere der hinweis auf zeugen
bitte denken sie an ihrer aussage
genehmigung hat sehr häufig zu
gedächtnisverlust bei zeugen geführt wir
sind mit unmengen an beweismaterial zu
geworfen worden und waren mit einstufung
von dokumenten die für uns nicht immer
nachvollziehbar konfrontiert es sind
einige puzzlestücke geblieben die wir
nicht einsetzen konnten rätselhafte
sachverhalte lassen hier aufgrund der
begrenzten redezeit lediglich auf vier
fälle eingeben
wussten sie dass anis amri der
vermeintliche attentäter des breitscheid
platzes am 29
2016 also fast ein halbes jahr vor dem
anschlag selbst ständig versucht hatte
berlin zu verlassen deutschland zu
verlassen es gab ein ausreise
sachverhalt in friedrichshafen wo die
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden mit einer
live ticker verfolgt hatten das
bundespolizeipräsidium potsdam sich
einschaltete der das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz involviert war und man
ihm diese aussage diese ausreise
untersagt hatte
die spurenlage am
kw ist das nächste beispiel dieser
ausschuss hat ein eigenes gutachten in
auftrag gegeben und es ist nicht
eindeutig nachvollziehbar weder an dna
spuren noch an der demoskopische spuren
das anis ambri diesen lkw gefahren hat
und sich durchgehend in dieser
fahrerkabine aufgehalten hatte es gibt
eine spurenlage einer weiteren person
wie bisher nicht identifiziert werden
konnte
die spuren im lkw zurückgelassen hatte
die fluchtroute von anis amri wir finden
es sehr rätselhaft dass wenige minuten
nach dem anschlag ein video aufgetaucht
ist einer videoüberwachungsanlage des
bahnhofs zoo wo sich annis ambri nicht
rennen sondern schlendern zum tatort in
und nicht vom tatort weg bewegt außerdem
ist die große blackbox die flucht von
ambi aus berlin
es gibt hier verdachtsmomente dass
kleinfamilien aus berlin ihn
möglicherweise zu dem attentat
angestiftet haben oder ihnen bei der
flucht geholfen haben sollen
der nächste für uns fragliche umstand
sind die todesumstände in sesto san
giovanni in italien
die hat ein mutmaßlicher attentäter
einen anschlag überlebt flüchtet und
kommt in italien plötzlich zu tode wir
haben uns die obduktion bilder angeguckt
es gibt schussverletzungen einschüsse
die nicht nach einem frontalen
schusswechsel sondern eher auf schüsse
auf der flucht aussehen lassen sie mich
abschließend zu einem möglichen mittäter
kommen der lange zeit auf dem
aktendeckel geführt wurde
biel berra abschiebungen von islamischen
gefährdern waren nicht möglich hier war
es plötzlich sehr schnell möglich am
ersten zwei 2017 wurde die länder
abgeschoben ohne sein handy vorher aus
bewertet zu haben ohne ihn ausgiebig
befragt zu haben ohne die frage zu
stellen wo er die letzten tage war die
spur von bilal ben amar verläuft sich
vielleicht dass er inzwischen wieder in
deutschland
der generalbundesanwalt hat sie sich
hierzu geäußert insbesondere der herr
salzmann und er berichtete über die
herangehensweise und er sagte die
beweise gegen ambri sein so erdrückend
gewesen dass diese würde er noch leben
für eine verurteilung gereicht hätte
alternative erklärungsversuche sind
überhaupt gar nicht
worden für uns als
untersuchungsausschuss war es viel
wichtiger andere thesen zu hinterfragen
alternative geschehen zu liter prüfen
ein beispiel was hierfür aus unserer
sicht versäumt wurde war dass man diese
asservate aus italien überhaupt gar
nicht angefordert hatte die pistole die
wir an die summaries sichergestellt
wurde ist überhaupt gar nicht untersucht
worden ist dies tatsächlich die tatwaffe
die verwendet worden ist um den lkw
fahrer am friedrich krause ufer zu
erschießen
es stellt sich die schuldfrage und wir
haben festgestellt dass zögerliches
handeln bei bundes- und landesbehörden
diesen anschlag begünstigt haben uns
fehlt es an einem politischen willen die
aufzuklären aktiv zu handeln und vor
allem den gefährder und personen die hin
nicht bleibe berechtigt sind außer
landes zu schaffen
ein blick auf die berliner polizei die
rot rot grüne regierung von berlin hat
eine schneise der verwüstung in der
deutschen und in der berliner
sicherheitslandschaft hinterlassen und
um die frage zu beantworten nein anis
amri war kein reiner polizei fall
und nein er war kein einzeltäter es gibt
seit 2006 17 einen internationalen
haftbefehl gegen eine person die sich
mutmaßlich noch in nord afrika aufhält
die frage nach dem anschlag selber ja
dieser anschlag hätte verhindert werden
können
und was ist daran schuld die offenen
grenzen die politik der offenen grenzen
dies war ein historischer fehler das ist
im ausschuss leider viel zu wenig
berücksichtigt worden
es gibt alternative erklärungsversuche
der spiegel hatte darüber berichtet
anfang 2017 hat ein luftschlag
stattgefunden ein luftschlag auf
libysche stellungen bei dem terroristen
getötet worden sind ich stelle die frage
ist es vielleicht so gewesen dass man
die kommunikation von anis ambri
überwacht hatte angezapft hatte genutzt
hatte um bewegungsdaten und
informationen zu bekommen und war dieser
anschlag vielleicht ein
kollateralschaden unserer
nachrichtendienste
frau merkel hat
versprechen abgegeben ich stelle fest
dieses versprechen einer aufklärung
wurde nicht eingelöst ich sage frau
bundeskanzlerin schämen sie sich an
dieser stelle bleibt mir nur noch den
hinterbliebenen und opfer mein beileid
mein mitgefühl auszusprechen nicht nur
mainz sondern meiner ganzen fraktion und
ich bitte im namen auch unserer wähler
alle hinterbliebenen alle opfer um
verzeihung für die fehler dieser
regierung und unserer
sicherheitsbehörden und ich verneige
mich hier stellvertretend dafür vielen
dank
der abschlussbericht des
untersuchungsausschusses ist 1900 seiten
stark es gibt sondern boten ein
gemeinsames der fraktion fdp linke und
bündnis 90/die grünen und es gibt von
der afd
ein sondervotum und dann gibt es das
allgemeine fazit der
koalitionsfraktionen jetzt sind wir für
die spd fritz felgentreu war der obmann
für die spd-fraktion herr präsident
meine damen und herren oder damen und
herren gäste die wir als angehörige der
toten vom breitscheidplatz und als
verletzte des anschlags heute eingeladen
haben
ich danke ihnen von herzen dass sie
unserer einladung gefolgt sind
es war der gedanke an das von ihnen
erlittenen unrecht an ihren
unwiederbringlichen verlust der uns
abgeordneten bei unserer arbeit in den
letzten dreieinhalb jahren ein ständiger
begleiter und man aber wenn du heute
darauf zurückblicken dann können wir ein
schlüssiges bild von den zusammenhängen
zeichnen unklarheiten in manchen details
beeinträchtigen das ergebnis im ganzen
nur wenig gleichzeitig sind wir weit
davon entfernt unsere arbeit mit einem
gefühl der befriedigung zu den akten zu
legen wir haben im gegenteil ein
schärferes bewusstsein für das ungenügen
das aus dem anspruch der innenpolitik
erwächst sicherheit für die menschen im
lande zu garantieren
in einem freien land wird der staat
diesen anspruch nie in vollem umfang
gerecht werden können
aber in eine diktatur erst recht nicht
der auftrag des untersuchungsausschusses
war es nachzuvollziehen wie es dem
attentäter gelingen konnte seinem ort zu
verüben
wie effektiv die zuständigen behörden
nach der tat aufgeklärt und missstände
beseitigt haben und welche
schlussfolgerungen für die zukunft dass
unseren erkenntnissen zu ziehen sind
über den ertrag von fast 150
vernehmungen und 450 stunden
beweisaufnahme haben wir einen
umfangreichen bericht vorgelegt der
vorsitzende des ausschusses der kollege
gröhe am montag dem herrn
bundespräsidenten übergeben hat an
dieser stelle möchte ich mich deshalb
aus der sicht der spd fraktion auf die
zentralen punkte konzentrieren
klar ist dass die besonderen umstände
der jahre 2015 und 2016 ambris planen
begünstigt haben die einwanderung von
über einer millionen menschen in kurzer
zeit hat nicht nur den grenzschutz
überfordert auch das bundesamt für
migration und flüchtlinge die polizeien
des bundes und der länder das
bundeskriminalamt und nicht zuletzt das
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz wurden
über ihre belastbarkeit hinaus
beansprucht dass ich unter
hunderttausenden normalen menschen auf
der suche nach einem besseren leben auch
terroristen befanden war zwar als
abstrakte gefahr erkannt und durch die
schrecklichen anschläge in brüssel nizza
und paris bestätigt worden
auch gelang es einzelne verdächtige zu
identifizieren so dass die zahl der
sogenannten gefährder in den akten der
sicherheitsbehörden sprunghaft anstieg
aber die kapazitäten wuchsen nicht im
gleichen gleichen maßstab mit
es kam zur überlastung des personals und
damit notwendigerweise zu defiziten in
der bearbeitung von einzelfällen
das hatte unmittelbare auswirkungen noch
die kooperation zwischen den
sicherheitsbehörden damit geheimdienste
und polizeibehörden des bundes und der
länder ihr vorgehen besser aufeinander
abstimmen können gibt es seit über 15
jahren das gemeinsame
terrorabwehrzentrum geht es in der
treptower puschkinallee elfmal war
alessandro ihr thema immer wieder wurden
die zuständigkeiten diskutiert und
geklärt maßnahmen erhoben und
ausgewertet aber am ende
erfolg wir planen den gefährde
abzuschieben schlug fehl
am ende schloss der durch die maschen
der netze die ihn halten sollten
eine fehleinschätzung die sicherlich
keine polizei in deutschland so noch
einmal wiederholen wird ihm dabei in
berlin fristete amri sein dasein als
drogenhändler damit verblasste im
bewusstsein der zuständigen beamten des
bildes terroristischen gefahr dass vor
dem des kleinkriminellen wie es hier der
großen stadt zu hunderten gibt formal
änderte sich nichts an der einschätzung
seiner gefährlichkeit
aber man nahm ihn weniger ernst dass
jemand mit drogen handeln und trotzdem
ein gewaltbereiter islamisten kann
konnten sich damals nur wenige
vorstellen zum beispiel beim lka nrw
heute weiß man es zu spät für die zwölf
menschen die sie betreuen
mir ist keine ruhe das in der kritischen
phase im herbst 2016 hat das berliner
landeskriminalamt mit seinem latein am
ende war und die rechtsgrundlagen für
die polizeiliche überwachung am ries
ausliefen nie geprüft wurde ob der
verfassungsschutz hätte in die bresche
springen können
die rechtlichen voraussetzungen waren
dafür erfüllt wäre amri aufgehalten
worden
wenn das bka den fall früher übernommen
hätte wenn der bundesnachrichtendienst
die libyschen telefonkontakte im februar
sorgfältiger überprüft hätte wenn der
verfassungsschutz im oktober ring
hinweisen aus marokko weniger halbherzig
nachgegangen wäre
wir werden es nie erfahren sicher
widerlegen konnten wir aber die these
die der damalige präsident des
verfassungsschutzes maßen nach dem
anschlag vertreten hat marisa ein reiner
polizei fall gewesen in wirklichkeit bei
der verfassungsschutz seit dem februar
2016 mit ihm befasst amri war ein
islamistisches netzwerk in deutschland
eingebunden
er hatte noch während der tat kontakt
mit einem mentor des der ihn von libyen
aus betreute für mutmaßungen es habe in
dem lkw oder am ort des anschlags
mindestens einen mittäter gegeben gibt
es allerdings keine beweise
viele schwächen ausgenutzt hat um vor
verfolgung geschützt zu bleiben sind
inzwischen behoben
im gemeinsamen terrorabwehrzentrum es
eine größere verbindlichkeit
arbeit erreicht worden sei eine neue
arbeitsgruppe risikomanagement
verbessert die fähigkeiten drohende
gefahr richtig einzuschätzen
die basis dafür ist das risiko
bewertungsinstrument rada ece das die
polizei seit 2017 nutzt
noch wichtiger ist sicherlich der
personalaufwand bereich staatsschutz und
verfassungsschutz sowie im bund sowohl
im bund wie in den ländern
gerade das land berlin hat hier große
anstrengungen übernommen und in einem
eigenen terrorabwehrzentrum experten für
alle aufgaben der gefahrenabwehr und der
telekommunikationsüberwachung
zusammengeführt bedanke mich dafür und
für seine anwesenheit beim
staatssekretär ad man den berliner
einsatzkräften war es am abend des
anschlags relativ schnell gelungen die
lage vor ort zu kontrollieren und
verletzte zu versorgen
man verliert sich im sinne des geltenden
rechts auch korrekt gegenüber menschen
die angst um ihre angehörigen hatten
allerdings gab es mit ihnen ein wenig
empathischen oft zu förmlichen umgang
für seine eltern vermisst braucht in dem
moment keine belehrung über die
standards die bei der identifizierung
eines leichnams einzuhalten sind
um den bedürfe um den bedürfnissen der
geschädigten besser gerecht zu werden
haben bund und länder beauftragte
berufen die den menschen selbst aber
auch den behörden mit rat und tat zur
seite stehen wie andré aus berlin
geflohen ist und woher er seine tatwaffe
hatte konnte der ausschuss nicht klären
es wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr
zu klären sein alle substanziellen
spuren sind aus ermittelt worden
einen durchbruch könnten nur neue zeugen
bringen die aber nicht zu erwarten sind
es wäre aber auch in überzogener
anspruch dass es gelingen könnte jedes
detail des geschehens vollständig
aufzuklären
am ende unseres langen weges stehen wir
vor der grundfrage der innenpolitik wie
viel die sicherheit der staat uns allen
schuldig ist
der bund und seine länder ergänzten
einander zu einer effektivität die den
terror selten den freiraum lässt um
unheil anzurichten
unser letzter zeuge der selbst aus der
islamistischen szene in berlin kommt
sagte uns dass er so einen anschlag in
deutschland nicht für möglich gehalten
er ist dabei möglich geworden an diesem
wintertag in berlin hat unser staat
seine bürgerinnen und bürger und ihre
gäste nicht so geschützt wie sie es
erwarten konnten dafür möchte ich sie
meine damen und herren auch im namen der
spd-fraktion um vergebung bitten
abschließend möchte ich mich bei dem
ausschussvorsitzenden angola und seinem
stellvertreter meinem kollegen erste mir
für ihre kompetente und geduldige
leitung bedanken
den mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
des ausschuss büros danke ich für ihre
herkulesarbeit und ihre engelsgeduld
auch der bundesregierung und der
zeuginnen und zeugen danken für ihre
bereitschaft unsere ermittlungen über
einen zeitraum von dreieinhalb jahren zu
unterstützen
es ist meine ehre dass ich in diesem
wichtigen untersuchungs ausschuss
mitarbeiten durfte und dass ich gerade
mit dieser rede auch den schlusspunkt
meines wirkens an diesem pult sitzen
kann
ich danke vielen dank
ob ihnen wünschen wir wünsche ich im
namen des ganzen hauses einen neustart
einen guten erfolgreichen neustart nach
zwei legislaturperioden wo sie sehr sehr
sehr viel getan haben unsere demokratie
zu verstärken und zu beschützen alles
gute lieber fritz felgentreu ja die
abschiedsrede die wir jetzt in diesen
wochen hören von den abgeordneten die
wissen dass sie aus dem bundestag
ausscheiden und dann auch der dank der
bundestagsvizepräsidentin
ich empfinde die tatsache dass sie
unserer einladung angenommen haben auch
als ein zeichen des vertrauens in unsere
demokratie ein zeichen des vertrauens
aber auch ein zeichen der erwartung dass
wir verantwortlich mit diesem
schrecklichen terroranschlag umgehen und
sie spüren dass es ein ganz großes
anliegen ist dass unsere kolleginnen und
kollegen betrifft und mit dem sie seit
jahren auch versucht haben die besten
und bestmöglichen schlussfolgerungen zu
ziehen ich freue mich sehr sie
anschließend zu einem direkten austausch
auch noch mal im persönlichen gespräch
begrüßen zu dürfen und mache jetzt
weiter in der debatte
nächster redner für die fw der wenn
diese sache so geschaltet haben auf den
tribünen opfer und angehörige von opfern
des terroranschlags auf dem
breitscheidplatz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
fan liebe opfer und hinterbliebenen ist
eine große ehre für uns dass wir heute
hier sind und der debatte folgende
vielen dank dafür
unsere arbeit startete vor drei jahren
mit einem großen versprechen der frau
bundeskanzlerin nämlich mit einem
versprechen der detaillierten und
umfassenden aufklärung
herr innenminister sie hatten dieses
versprechen erneuert zur hälfte der
arbeit dieses untersuchungsausschusses
mit ihrer forderung nach maximaler
transparenz das was sie wissen sollten
sollte auch diese untersuchungsausschuss
wissen das waren ihre worte was wir
allerdings im untersuchungsausschuss
seitens der bundesregierung erlebt haben
war eine aufklärung mit angezogener
handbremse akten die massiv gespart
würden seitenteile die entnommen wurden
akten die zu spät oder gar nicht
geliefert würden wichtige zeugen wie den
fahrern führer der bieten die noch fusi
mit let moschee der uns bis heute
vorenthalten worden ist diese
verweigerungshaltung der bundesregierung
hat dazu geführt dass wir eben nicht
alle steine umdrehen konnten die wir
hätten umdrehen sollen und dass es auch
eine bittere bilanz dieses
untersuchungsausschusses
was aber unsere arbeit ans licht
gebracht hat das wirft fundamentale
fragen an die organisation unserer
inneren sicherheit in deutschland auf
dem breitscheidplatz scheiterten eben
nicht einzelne gescheiterte eine
struktur und deswegen ist die einführung
des starts drei jahren ist oder die
forderung nach pauschal personelle
aufstockung von sicherheitsbehörden eben
nicht die richtige antwort auf den
anschlag am berliner breitscheidplatz
nach dem nsu skandal
nach diesem anschlag müssen wir uns
endlich diesen systemischen versagen
widmen und diese systemische versagen in
den strukturen beheben liebe kollegen
kollegen wir haben in deutschland 40
sicherheitsbehörden die teilweise wenn
wir auch die länder blicken viel zu
klein sind um die aufgaben die sie
erledigen sollen überhaupt noch
zustimmen
ein schillerndes beispiel unsere
untersuchungsausschuss arbeit war der
verfassungsschutz
mecklenburg vorpommern mit seinen 70
mitarbeitern wo über jahre hinweg in
mehreren fällen sich nicht an geltendes
recht gehalten worden ist und nach dem
anschlag ein hinweis auf mögliche
hintermänner unterstützung von sunny
entgegen einer gesetzlichen
verpflichtung nicht an die
polizeibehörden weitergegeben worden ist
polizeiarbeit kinder trieben wurde wo
ministerien wo parlamente nichts davon
mitbekommen haben
eine solches eigenleben von
verfassungsschutzbehörden können wir
nicht tolerieren und deswegen müssen wir
hier gesetzgeberisch tätig werden und
die parlamentarische nachrichtendienst
kontrolle
nachschärfen das ist ein wesentlicher
baustein auch unsere erkenntnisse wir
haben ja mit dem nachrichtendienst
beauftragen einen konkreten vorschlag
gemacht liebe kollegin kollegen
strukturelle defizite haben sich aber
auch bei der führung von
vertrauenspersonen also spitzeln aus
extremistischen szenen gezeigt
40 spitzel von sieben
sicherheitsbehörden beim nsu die über
zehn jahre lang nichts gewusst haben
wollen
acht spitzel bei anni somebody über
eineinhalb jahre nichts gewusst haben
wollen eine vp 0 1 die als einzige
hinweise geliefert hat die man in den
sicherheitsbehörden großenteils ganz
ernst genommen hat wo man eine
vertrauensperson über 15 jahre hinweg
alimentiert hat wo man straftaten
geduldet hat wer diese
vertrauenspersonen will und ich will sie
der muss doch jetzt zum schluss kommen
dass eine gesetzliche grundlage zur
vertrauensperson gerade im bereich der
strafverfolgung gefahrenabwehr notwendig
ist und auch das ist ein ergebnis
unserer untersuchungsausschuss arbeit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
man könnte man könnte viel noch hier
sagen zum thema der analysefähigkeit von
sicherheitsbehörden und da komme ich
auch zur anderen einschätzungen wie hahn
felgentreu was das thema und islamischen
verhalten how to the west angeht es
zeigt dass das fachwissen in deutschland
sehr unterschiedlich verteilt ist und
das ist ganz klarer fehler war oder dass
man jets das attentat als verschlüsselte
telegramm chats die man hatte überhaupt
nicht ausgewertet hat das ist ein
problem in der struktur und deswegen
müssen wir auch strukturen angeben ich
möchte aber meine letzte minute ihnen
den opfern und hinterbliebenen was sie
uns berichtet haben nach dem anschlag
wie es ihnen ergangen ist es ist
wirklich beschämend und ich glaube dass
wir immer noch nicht optimal vorbereitet
sind in deutschland auf terroristische
anschläge
was einem mitfühlenden einen
respektvollen vor allem einen
unterstützenden umgang mit ihnen den
opfern und hinterbliebenen angeht ich
glaube nicht dass opfer beauftragt er
alleine ausreichen wir brauchen eine
echte armut stelle die auch über die
jahre hinweg ansprechpartner ist die
hilfe leistet bei finanziellen
ansprüchen und deswegen schlagen wir
unter anderem vor die bereits
existierende koordinierungsstelle für
den opferschutz nur auszubauen gerade
auch für terroristische anschläge in
deutschland und ein zweiter punkt der
mir wichtig ist sie sind nicht vergessen
auch nach diesem anschlag nicht andere
länder wie spanien die frankreich haben
einen besseren umgang mit opfern der
elfte märz er ist der europäische
gedanke für opfer terroristischer gewalt
und ich finde es würde uns gut anstehen
wenn wir diesen tag den elften märz hier
auch in deutschland zu einem nationalen
gedenktag für die opfer terroristischer
gewalt machen egal ob nsu egal ob die
opfer von istanbul
egal ob die opfer vom breitscheidplatz
wir werden sie nicht vergessen
auch nach dem ende des
untersuchungsausschusses nicht
wir haben
wir haben nach dem nsu die chance auf
strukturelle reformen verpasst
eine zusage der bundesregierung ist aber
noch offen herr seehofer sie hatten
gesagt sie werden sich ganz genau
anschauen was dieser
untersuchungsausschuss in seinem
abschlussbericht berichtet und
entsprechend handelt es liegt es an
ihrem nachfolger oder ihre nachfolgerin
konsequenzen zu ziehen
strukturelle konsequenzen zu ziehen ich
sage diese bundesregierung und der
kommen hinzu wenn es um eine echte
reform der föderalen
sicherheitsarchitektur geht wenn es um
mehr parlamentarische kontrolle geht
wenn es um einen besseren opferschutz
geht haben sie die unterstützung der
freien demokraten und ich würde mich
freuen wenn wir diese lehren aus diesem
anschlag dann auch tatsächlich ziehen
vielen vielen dank benjamin strasser
[Applaus]
der obmann für die liberalen im
untersuchungsausschuss und im reigen der
frauen in dem fall geht es jetzt weiter
die opfer für die linke war in diesem
untersuchungsausschuss martina renner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren der
demokratischen fraktion der erste
untersuchungsausschuss dieser legislatur
ist mit der aufgabe angetreten die
hintergründe des anschlags auf dem
breitscheidplatz lückenlos aufzuklären
wir hatten den anspruch die im vorfeld
des anschlags begangenen fehler der
sicherheitsbehörden konkret zu benennen
und wir hatten den auftrag vorschläge zu
unterbreiten wie die sicherheit in
diesem land verbessert werden könnte die
bundesregierung sie gab den
hinterbliebenen der zwölf getöteten
und in vielen verletzten ein versprechen
die aufklärungsarbeit des ausschusses
uneingeschränkt zu unterstützen
wir haben als ausschuss festgestellt der
attentäter war vor der tat in
islamistische strukturen in deutschland
eingebunden
er hat mit den relevantesten personen
der szene engsten kontakt gehabt er hat
versuchte sich die zur durchführung der
tat notwendigen mittel zu beschaffen
und er hat monatelang auf den moment
gewartet diesen anschlag zu begehen
die zuständigen sie hatten von all
diesen dingen kenntnis und haben dennoch
nicht rechtzeitig gehandelt
auf seiten der polizei wurden durch weg
durch wick und das gilt für die lkws wie
das für das bundeskriminalamt durchweg
falsche bewertungen vorgenommen und
fahrlässig die notwendigen maßnahmen
nicht getroffen
die geheimdienste sie hatten mehr
informationen über den attentäter und
sein umfeld als unmittelbar nach dem
anschlag und auch bis heute von
hinzugegeben der attentäter des
anschlags er hat nicht alleine gehandelt
er wurde vor seiner tat in deutschland
ideologisch geschult logistisch wie
finanziell unterstützt er war kein
einzeltäter dies herauszuarbeiten ist
verdienst der demokratischen opposition
im untersuchungsausschuss
aber die sicherheitsbehörden sie
klammern sich an dieses bild des
einzeltäters warum eigentlich
wenn man weiter mit dieser falschen
konzeption des einzeltäters weiter macht
wird man zukünftigen terror nicht
verhindern können die fiktion des
alleine in einem vakuum agierenden
terroristen gefährdet heute im
europäischen rat mit verschiedenen
tagesordnungspunkten ich freue mich
natürlich auf das mittagessen mit dem
un-generalsekretär antonio guterres und
dort werden multilaterale themen
klimaschutz biodiversität aber auch die
pandemie natürlich eine rolle spielen
wie können wir die menschen auf der
ganzen welt mit impfstoff versorgen wie
in unserem normalen europäischen rat die
das thema der pandemie bekämpfung auch
in unseren reihen die data variante
macht uns natürlich sorgen und ich werde
dafür werben dass wir noch koordinierte
vorgehen auch gerade bei der einreise
aus virusvarianten gebieten
wir werden uns über das impfen
unterhalten und auch unsere aktivitäten
in afrika
wir werden die ökonomischen bewertungen
vornehmen der recovery fand ist jetzt
angelaufen das deutsche programm ist
auch dem rat zur empfehlung und
zustimmung vorgeschlagen das sind
wichtige punkte im zusammenhang mit
corona und wir werden dann über die das
verhältnis zur türkei sprechen und zu
russland und bei russland auch
schlussfolgerung ziehen was können wir
über die margarine prinzipien hinaus in
der kooperation machen
die antworten wir geschlossen auf die
provokation und wie können wir
vielleicht auch gesprächsformat
herstellen denn konflikte kann man am
besten lösen
das hat man am amerikanischen
präsidenten gesehen wenn man auch
miteinander spricht also eine volle
tagesordnung dankeschön ich freue mich
auf die beratung
dieses schreiben wurde ja von vielen
ländern unterzeichnet ja ich hab ja
sofort darauf reagiert lesen sie das
doch was sagen sie denen heute es geht
ja nicht um homosexualität sondern um
kinder und die eltern aber man
kritisiert deshalb es ist ein
ungarisches gesetz können sie
ausrutschen nein das gesetz schon
verkündet und veröffentlicht nein ich
kämpfe immer für die rechte der menschen
ich bin ein freiheitskämpfer unter den
kommunisten war die homosexualität
bestraft und ich habe für deren rechte
gekämpft also ich verteidige die rechte
der homosexuellen aber in diesem gesetz
geht es nicht darum sondern um die
rechte der kinder und eltern
das richtet sich nicht gegen die
homosexualität und gegen homosexuelle in
dem gesetz geht es darum dass die eltern
entscheiden können wie sie ihre kinder
sexuell erziehen wollen das ist
ausschließlich das euch der eltern darum
geht es in dem gesetz das war die
ankünfte in brüssel zum europäischen rat
viktor orban und angela merkel angela
merkel die heute morgen hier im
bundestag ihre mutmaßlich letzte
regierungserklärung gehalten hat just zu
diesem europäischen rat und wir haben
natürlich auch heute im verlaufe des
tages einen blick in richtung brüssel
derzeit diskutiert hier und debattiert
der bundestag den bericht zum
untersuchungsausschuss des
terroranschlags auf dem breitscheidplatz
und es spricht im moment martina renner
die obfrau der linken auf dem weg zu
einer besseren allgemeinen strukturellen
ausrichtung der sicherheitsbehörden vor
zu setzen
die aufgabe wird sein die auch die
rechte der opfer weiter zu verbessern
und wir müssen das
untersuchungsausschuss recht im sinne
von rechtsdurchsetzung und transparenz
zu stärken
vielen dank es gibt ein sondervotum der
linken der fdp und der bündnisgrünen ein
gemeinsames sondervotum das ist durchaus
häufigen untersuchungsausschüssen dass
die oppositionsfraktionen das etwas
anders sehen als die
koalitionsfraktionen so auch in diesem
fall jetzt hören wir für die grünen die
opfer war im untersuchungsausschuss
irene mihalic sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen verehrte gäste heute beenden
wir den parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss zum bisher
schlimmsten islamistischen anschlag in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland
und auch wenn auch über drei jahren
arbeit noch viele fragen offen sind so
konnten wir doch fünf zentrale punkte
herausarbeiten
punkt eins die bundessicherheitsbehörden
tragen einen großen teil der
verantwortung zu unrecht hat die
bundesregierung nach dem anschlag mit
dem finger in so ziemlich alle
richtungen gezeigt vor allem in die
länder nordrhein-westfalen und berlin
nur nicht auf sich selbst
punkt 2 der anschlag hätte verhindert
werden können wenn man im gemeinsamen
terrorabwehrzentrum die gefährlichkeit
eines ambris richtig eingeschätzt hätte
es gab konkrete hinweise dass er
anschläge begehen wollte doch diese
hinweise wurden nicht richtig analysiert
punkt 3 ambri war kein einzeltäter und
auch kein kleinkrimineller er war teil
eines statistischen netzwerks mit
direktem draht zum e s und er hat sich
sogar noch am anschlag
über mehrere stunden hinweg mit anderen
gefährdern getroffen
auch das wurde weitgehend ausgeblendet
dass also mögliche mitwisser
unterstützer und vielleicht sogar mit
täter immer noch auf freiem fuß sein
könnten ist eine relevante gefahren
damen und herren und vier alles amri war
kein reiner polizei fall der damalige
präsident des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz hans-georg maßen hat
gebetsmühlenartig immer wieder das
gegenteil behauptet heute haben wir
warum denn kurz vor dem ende dieses
untersuchungsausschusses wurden dem
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz noch
akten gefunden die uns aber schon von
drei jahren hätten geliefert werden
müssen jetzt wissen wir dass bfv war
schon 2015 an annes ambri und seinem
umfeld dran
so gab es kurz vor dem anschlag aber es
hat nicht alles getan um zu verhindern
dass ambri vom radar verschwinden
punkt 5 das bundeskriminalamt hat nach
dem anschlag mit dass ermittelt was
nötig war um die these these vom
einzeltäter zu bestätigen ob dna-spuren
bewegungsdaten kontakte zur
organisierten kriminalität oder zu
anderen gefährdern vor wem er das viele
geld die drogen und auch die waffe bekam
bei der frage ob ampel noch komplizen
hatte wurde eben nicht jeder stein
umgedreht ganz nach dem motto der täter
ist tot der fall ist gelöst
nein liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
vielen ungeklärten fragen sind weiterhin
eine offene wunde die es nach und nach
zu heilen gilt aber aber die gute nacht
die gute nachricht ist dass wir das auch
können wenn wir die notwendigen
konsequenzen entschlossen ziehen wie wir
sie auch in unserem abschluss bericht
aufgezeigt haben nach diesem
schrecklichen anschlag die lehren daraus
zu ziehen das schulden wir nicht zuletzt
den opfern und hinterbliebenen denen
unser ganzes mitgefühl gilt
zum schluss möchte ich mich bei den
anderen mitgliedern des
untersuchungsausschusses insbesondere
der demokratischen opposition bedanken
und bei den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern ohne die wir diese wichtige
aufklärungsarbeit nicht hätten leisten
können ganz herzlich wieder diesen
landwirte ihren herrlich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich danke ihnen nächster redner für die
cdu csu fraktion dr volker ullrich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren dass sie als
angehöriger der opfer heute auf der
ehrentribüne platz genommen haben ist
für uns eine ehre weil es deutlich macht
wofür wir in vielen hundert stunden
gearbeitet haben
um antworten zu finden auf ihre
berechtigten fragen auf die anliegen der
aufklärung und darum dass der staat
nicht ruhen darf bis alle offenen fragen
geklärt sind
das macht nichts ungeschehen ist kein
trost
aber nehmen sie uns ab dass wir
stellvertretend für das gesamte haus
nicht ruhen wollten ist wichtige fragen
geklärt und die entscheidende
konsequenzen daraus gezogen wurden sind
und das erste was uns umtreibt war der
umgang mit den angehörigen der opfer
dieser war völlig indiskutabel ja würde
nur wenn es keine ansprechpartner gab
keine informationen und manche
angehörige als allererstes vom staat
rechnungen bekommen haben
für gerichtsmedizinische untersuchungen
ist das etwas was uns heute noch
beschämend muss noch dafür bitte ich um
vergebung
aber sind auch lehren daraus gezogen
wurden nicht nur die einrichtung eines
opfer beauftragten oder die reform des
sozialen entschädigungsrecht sondern
auch die einführung eines
oberstaatsanwalts zeigt der staat darf
künftig opfer nicht alleinlassen der
opferschutz muss im mittelpunkt der
politik stehen aber die frage die sich
natürlich bei dieser debatte stellt und
auch während der vielen hundert stunden
war diese tat zu verhindern gewesen und
auf diese hypothetische frage gibt es
keine abschließende gewissheit aber es
drängt sich auf dass zahlreiche fehler
und fehleinschätzungen in den strukturen
aber auch ganz persönliche art letztlich
zu dieser tat führen konnten ohne dass
es einen einzigen verantwortlichen
es beginnt mit der einreise der
attentäter war bereits in italien wegen
einer schweren gewalttat vorbestraft nur
war es niemandem bekannt weil diese
information nicht in den datensystemen
eingespeist war und deswegen hat dieser
ausschuss auch offengelegt dass wir im
schengen raum in europa einen besseren
datenaustausch zwischen den
sicherheitsbehörden brauchen und diese
forderung ist in den letzten jahren
bereits erfüllt worden das bitte ich zur
kenntnis zu nehmen
aber wichtig ist auch dass weitere
aufenthaltsbeendende maßnahmen nicht
durchgeführt worden sind
auch wenn es damals bereits das geltende
recht hergab
so ist auch wichtig dass wir nicht nur
den rechtlichen rahmen schaffen
besonders das geltende recht auch
angewandt wird und nichtsdestotrotz
haben wir weitere verbesserungen
geschaffen über den datenaustausch bis
hin zum neuen aus dem zentralregister
dass die ausländerbehörden bei
aufenthaltsbeendende maßnahmen
werke von ihren befugnissen gebrauch
machen und wir gefährde auch schneller
außer landes bringen können
wir müssen noch feststellen dass die
gefährlichkeit des attentäters
offenkundig war die islamistische
gesinnung war bekannt und eine der
größten fehleinschätzungen war das durch
den drogenhandel man angenommen hat er
sei kein potenzieller terroristen werde
und deswegen wurde im herbst 2016
überwachung auch beendet eine fatale
entscheidung
er war fast ein dutzend mal thema im
gemeinsame terrorabwehrzentrum und die
frage ist sind lehren daraus gezogen
worden
und die antwort ist ja die organisation
des gemeinsamen terrorabwehrzentrum es
ist verbessert worden
die berichtspflicht ist intensiver die
protokolle sind deutlicher aber auch bei
der bewertung von gefährdern sind fünf
neue ansätze geschaffen worden
bis zu diesem anschlag gab es eine
personenbezogene bewertung und die hat
im ergebnis zu dieser fehleinschätzung
geführt jetzt werden gefährde nicht mit
neuen sondern mit 73 merkmalen bewertet
wortes umfeld mit einbezogen wird
doch das system von haiti hat man ein
besseres system wir schaffen um
gefährder zu überwachen und so auf dem
schirm zu haben ich glaube dass es auch
eine wichtige erkenntnis die bereits
umgesetzt ist aber die frage bleibt
warum ist der attentäter nicht in haft
genommen worden
es gab verschiedene delikte
körperverletzung drogenhandel betrug
weil jedes delikt für sich allein
genommen vielleicht zu wenig war
weil falsche einschätzung vorlagen aber
mittlerweile ist durch das system der
sammelverfahren ein instrument auf
justizieller ebene geschaffen worden das
verfahren gebündelt werden und das bei
vorliegen von solchen straftaten eine
untersuchungshaft und eine aburteilung
möglich erscheint auch das hat sich doch
diesen untersuchungsausschuss geändert
was ist wichtig
doch ich glaube wir müssen uns insgesamt
nach wie vor die bedrohung schnell
wir müssen uns gewahr werden dass die
bedrohungen für diesen freiheitlichen
rechtsstaat doch extremisten jeder art
stark ist und groß ist rechtsextremismus
linksextremismus aber auch der
dschihadismus der islamistische
extremismus ist eine gefahr
und die müssen wir begegnen doch
kompetenz und doch personal
deswegen freut es mich dass in den
letzten jahren es gemeinsam gelungen ist
in den sicherheitsbehörden mehr personal
zu schaffen aber mehr personal allein
reicht nicht aus
wir brauchen die entsprechenden
rechtlichen kompetenzen und befugnisse
wir brauchen auch einen
verfassungsschutz der sich diese
strukturen ansieht mit den
entsprechenden rechtlichen möglichkeiten
aber es geht auch um prävention und der
radikalisierung
kein mensch wird als islamist geboren
menschen werden dazu sie werden verführt
und radikalisiert und auch das muss der
staat angehen damit niemand erst zu
einem gefährt er wird insgesamt
ist zu sagen dass die arbeit in dieser
untersuchungsausschuss vor einem großen
kollegial miteinander geprägt waren von
der gemeinsamen überzeugung antworten zu
finden und antworten zu liefern
er wird das unsere gemeinsame
überzeugung schuldig sind aber vor allen
dingen auch den opfern und ihren
angehörigen
denn heute noch einmal unsere
anteilnahme gehört herzlichen dank
volker ullrich wie die redner vor ihm
und das bundeskabinett hat 2018 weil die
sorge um den umgang mit den opfern und
auch mit den hinterbliebenen das ist ja
immer wieder deutlich geworden in der
aussprache ist sehr groß und 2018 hat
die bundesregierung einen beauftragten
der bundesregierung für anliegen von
opfern und hinterbliebenen von
terroristischen straftaten im inland
ändern dass es derzeit etwa frank
verehrte angehörige hinterbliebene
freundinnen und freunde der opfer
wir können nicht mal erahnen nicht mal
erahnen wie groß die trauer der schmerz
und die dunkelheit sein muss für sie die
sie einen geliebten menschen verloren
haben physisch verletzt oder
traumatisiert wurden und deswegen danke
dass sie hier heute bei uns und mit uns
sind ihnen allen gilt unser volles
mitgefühl und unsere ganze solidarität
meine damen und herren
wir wissen auch um die enormen
leistungen aller einsatzkräfte am
anschlagsort den rettungskräften erst
helferinnen den polizistinnen und
polizisten bei denen dieses verbrechen
unauslöschliche spuren hinterlassen hat
ihnen allen gilt unser großer dank meine
damen und herren
unser ausschuss hat versucht den
hintergründen der terrortat vom
breitscheidplatz auf den grund zu gehen
wie konnte es dazu kommen dass
angeklungen dass ein bekannter islamist
der voll im fokus der behörden stand ein
gefährder den schwersten islamistischen
anschlag der deutschen geschichte
begegnen konnte und ich kann sagen wir
haben das als fraktionen der opposition
wir grünen mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen der linken und der fdp wirklich
versucht aufzuklären jeden stein
umzudrehen an jedem baum zu rütteln
alles gegen das licht zu halten und es
sind zahlreiche neue zusammenhänge und
fakten offenbar geworden aber auch viele
fragen auf zu viele fragen haben wir
keine antworten gefunden und das treibt
uns oben und das kann uns keine ruhe
lassen meine damen und herren einen
punkt möchte ich aus greifen die v-leute
ob beim oktoberfest anschlag beim buback
raf bord beim nsu oder auch hier beim
breitscheidplatz geheimhaltung und
quellenschutz alles gut und richtig aber
nach solch gravierenden terrortaten herr
seehofer praktisch keine akten aus dem
bereich so viele schwärzungen keine
zeugeneinvernahmen der quelle noch nicht
mal der v-mann führung herr minister das
ist eine massive behinderung unserer
arbeit wir hier als organ der ersten
gewalt mit einer aufklärungs
legitimation unmittelbar aus der
verfassung die policy der
bundesregierung diesen bereich komplett
der parlamentarischen kontrolle zu
entziehen ist vollkommen in
september eine damen- und zum schluss
auch das wurde gesagt der staatliche
umgang mit opfern und hinterbliebenen
der anschläge und bei großen
unglücksfällen von nationaler tragweite
muss sich gravierend ändern
wir haben von den hinterbliebenen des
anschlags herzzerreißende und tief
verstörende geschichten gehört wie sie
teilweise den umgang des deutschen
staates erlebt haben explizit ausnehmen
von der kritik möchte ich kurt beck und
ihm für seine arbeit danken aber es viel
zu häufig es fehlt zu häufig auch bei
mendes hanau halle germanwings absturz
oder breitscheidplatz an einem
geordneten würdigen empathischen umgang
mit den opfern und hinterbliebenen ihnen
begegnet zu oft ein kalter
bürokratischer staat der nicht in der
lage ist den menschen angemessen zu
begegnen wir müssen das ändern
ganz herzlichen dank
vielen dank dr konstantin von notz
ich danke ihnen
nächster redner für die spd-fraktion
mahmud ist er war der stellvertretende
vorsitzende des untersuchungsausschusses
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren
hinterbliebene diese todesopfer beklagen
sehr geehrte damen und herren die sie
verletzungen an leib und seele davon
getragen haben
so wie ihr verlust ihre verletzung teil
ihres lebens ist so ist dieser anschlag
teil der staats geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland noch teil
unseres lebens geworden die die wir im
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
gemeinsam bis auf vielleicht eine
ausnahme mit dem anspruch an die würde
der opfer
diese bürde der aufklärung verfolgt
haben ihre verluste ihre verletzungen
sind tiefe wunden 12 ermordete menschen
über 170 verletzte rissen eine
mindestens genauso tiefe wunde in die
seele der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung dieses landes menschen die
in verantwortung stehen bei unseren
sicherheitsbehörden in ministerien und
parlamenten tragen ebenso wunden davon
nämlich die kunden in ihrer
verantwortung der verantwortung dass so
ein anschlag auf deutschem boden
geschehen konnte
für diejenigen die den verlust eines
menschen beklagen wird diese wunden die
heilen die verletzten überlebenden
werden versuchen mit der zeit diese
wunden ländern zu lassen oder ihre
wunden und den schmerz zu lindern jeden
donnerstag in sitzungswochen haben wir
versucht zur linderung durch die
aufklärung über drei jahre in diesem
untersuchungsausschuss beizutragen
aufklärung dessen was passierte als ein
sittlich verkommener 24-jähriger
terrorist geliebte menschen in den tod
riss und menschen verletzte linderung
beginnt da wo man dinge auch offen und
ehrlich aus und anspricht unsere balance
von freiheit und sicherheit stimmte
nicht
das sicherheitsversprechen unseres
staates war löchrig so konnte dieser
anschlag geschehen sicherheitsbehörden
unsere sicherheitsbehörden waren
überfordert weil sie zu wenig personal
hatten ein umstand den wir in dieser
wahlperiode und in der letzten
wahlperiode mühsam auch verändert haben
zweitens wir können und dürfen menschen
mit ungeklärten identitäten nicht frei
in unserem land rumlaufen lassen alles
amri hatte alias identitäten in
zweistelliger höhe
wenn zweifel an der identität eines
ausländers bestehen oder jemand nicht
mitwirkt oder gar betrübt dann gehört er
in staatlichem gewahrsam bis er diese
identität auch festgestellt hat dass
bank müssen wir zwar einer
identitätsfeststellung behörde und zu
einer identitätsfeststellung gewahrsams
behörde weiter entwickeln die
zuständigkeit von sicherheitsbehörden
seien weiteres drittes thema hoch mobile
gefährder der attentäter durch kreuz
durchquerte nrw berlin baden württemberg
niedersachsen zahlreiche kleine delikte
die für sich genommen keine besondere
relevanz hatten aber in ihrer summe und
ihrer bündelung hätten für eine
einstellung auch sorgen können die
karikatur dessen ist das beispielsweise
nordrhein westfalen sagte
da kommt eine gefährliche person und auf
der anderen seite konnte man während
diese personen sich schon bewegte nicht
angemessen reagieren während dieser
attentäter ländergrenzen innerhalb der
bundesrepublik übertrat konnten wir die
grenzen des föderalismus nicht
überwinden auch das gehört zur wahrheit
viele enten haben wir zusammen gebunden
und eine besondere anekdote an anekdote
kann man das gar nicht nennen ein
besonderer fall lässt mir keine ruhe
der generalbundesanwalt lädt streitende
behörden wir das lka nrw und das
bundeskriminalamt zu einem klärenden
gespräch über die einstufung über die
besondere einstufung dieses attentäters
ein um eine einvernehmliche
arbeitsgrundlage
schaffen zu können das muss man sich
vorstellen da werden gestandene
beamtinnen und beamte beim
generalbundesanwalt in
anführungsstrichen vorgeladen und dann
menschelt es unbescholtene tüchtige
beamte die sich nie etwas zuschulden
haben kommen lassen haben eine
eins-zu-eins-situation würde eine dem
sagt unsere quelle ist exzellent wir
müssen da weiter ermitteln und der
andere sagt ihm diese quelle macht so
viel arbeit sie muss kaputt geschrieben
werden das ist eine situation die mich
umtreibt die mir abends vor dem
schlafengehen teilweise wenn ich immer
daran denkt oder wenn ich aus dem
ausschuss rauskommen keine ruhe gelassen
hat war das vielleicht der wendepunkt wo
wir hätten in sachen einstufungen in
sachen verhinderung des anschlages
nochmal den entsprechenden wendepunkt
gesetzt haben können viele enten haben
wir zusammen gefunden einige sind offen
geblieben die abstrakten fragen sind
hier angesprochen worden nicht alles
haben wir im lichte der öffentlichkeit
auch besprechen können
das hat teilweise damit zu tun dass die
bundesregierung sich auf
nichtöffentlichkeit vertraulichkeit
geheimhaltung zurückgezogen hat das
empfinde ich zumindest als auftrag an
den gesetzgeber die bundesregierung hat
uns gezeigt dass wir gesetze ändern
müssen um genau da hin zu gucken wo sie
sich in das licht der
nichtöffentlichkeit zurückgezogen hat
und weiter versuchen wir zurückzuziehen
wenn wir diese gesetze nicht auf den
prüfstand stellen und gegebenenfalls
auch verändern
der täter muss mit der tat nicht mehr
leben der zehnte sich wir schon
angehörige
verletzte staatsdiener rinnen und
staatsdiener mit dem markt bürgerinnen
und bürger und die gäste der
bundesrepublik deutschland nicht
geschützt zu haben und nicht schützen zu
können
vergeben sie uns als staatsdiener rinnen
und staatsdiener damit wir uns selber
vergeben können um dem versprechen zu
dienen dass sich so ein anschlag nie
wieder in vergleichbarer weise ereignet
nicht in deutschland nicht in europa und
durch gute zusammenarbeit auch nicht in
der welt ich danke in aller demut für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
den opfern und hinterbliebenen für ihre
anwesenheit
es war mir eine persönliche ehre mit
allen abgeordneten des
untersuchungsausschusses an dieser
aufklärung gemeinsam zu arbeiten wir
haben geliefert
wir haben bestritten wir haben aber
immer bis auf eine ausnahme das gleiche
ziel verfolgt allerdings mit
verschiedenen prioritätensetzungen
darauf bin ich stolz ist es mir eine
ehre und ich hoffe dass wir ihrem
anspruch ihrer würde mit dieser bürde
gerecht geworden sind
vielen dank für offen vielen dank
das denn her ich danke ihnen und der
letzte redner in dieser debatte
alexander throm für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werde
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
opfer und angehörige und betroffene
es ist gut und uns eine ehre sie heute
hier zu haben auch wenn es sicherlich
erneut ein schwerer gang für sie heute
gewesen sein muss denn kein
untersuchungsausschuss kann die opfer
wieder lebendig machen kann ihre
verletzungen an körper und seele heilen
wir können mit ihnen fühlen das tun wir
nehmen an ihrem schicksal
großen anteil aber wir können vor allem
unser jetziges wissen aus dem
untersuchungsausschuss auch dafür nutzen
um unnötiges leid in zukunft zu
vermeiden
wie war die situation 2016
wir hatten in deutschland viele jahre
oder vielleicht sogar jahrzehnte einer
weitgehenden liberalisierung und öffnung
in der migrationspolitik hinter uns und
das durchaus in ganz verschiedenen
regierungskoalitionen und
konstellationen
wir hatten 2015 2016 einen großen strom
von menschen die schutz suchen in
deutschland und in europa und wir haben
zu recht diesen menschen den schutz
gewährt aber es waren auch manche dabei
die diese situation für ihre perfide
ziele missbrauchen wollten und
missbraucht haben
der spätere attentäter war einer davon
und ja das gehört zur wahrheit auch dazu
auf diese situation
25 10 216 war unser liberalisiert das
ausländerrecht unsere migrationspolitik
unsere behörden damals nicht vorbereitet
und deswegen hat es auch als konsequenz
hieraus ein umsteuern gegeben wir haben
in vielen bereichen das ausländerrecht
die regularien des verfahren geschärft
und beschleunigt beispielsweise bei der
feststellung der personen es wurde
erwähnt in der euro sackt datei hätten
wir gewusst wer da kommt aus italien
dann hätten wir die gefährlichkeit
früher und besser einschätzen können und
es wäre nicht möglich gewesen mit über
10 a aktivitäten in deutschland
herumzureisen dies alles ist durch viele
gesetzesänderung erst zum schluss oder
zuletzt beim ausländerzentralregister in
der letzten sitzungswoche heute so nicht
mehr möglich aber auch da haben nicht
alle fraktionen diesen verbesserungen
zugestimmt
unsere ermittlungen haben auch gezeigt
dass beispielsweise das land nordrhein
westfalen bei der abschiebung des
ausreisepflichtigen attentäters nicht
konsequent genug war damals durchaus
kein einzelfall zu wenig konsequenz in
der handhabung der durchaus gegebenen
rechtlichen möglichkeiten heute hat sich
hier eine bewusstseinsänderung in der
deutschen politik ergeben und auch da
haben wir die möglichkeiten geschäft
etwa beim geordneten rückkehr gesetz
2009/10 von herr kollege
wenn die ihre aussage für die spd damals
schon gewusst hätten dann hätten wir die
mitwirkung sagt die sie angesprochen
haben
auch damals schon ins gesetz machen
können gut dass es heute jedenfalls zu
dieser erkenntnis gekommen ist und wir
haben auch festgestellt dass wir
durchaus auch probleme in der
zusammenarbeit der verschiedenen ebenen
in unserer föderalen und gliederten
staatsstruktur haben zwischen
landeskriminalämtern bka
nachrichtendiensten und den
ausländerbehörden das hat zb zu
fehleinschätzungen der gefährlichkeit
geführt und dann auch das entsprechende
konsequenzen nicht gezogen wurden diese
wurden jetzt beispielsweise im
gemeinsamen terrorabwehrzentrum gipfel
getroffen indem dort eine bessere
zusammenarbeit und vor allem eine
steuerung protokollierung und umsetzung
beschlossen ist es hat sich aber auch
gezeigt dass wir durchaus strukturelle
probleme in unserer
sicherheitsarchitektur haben ich möchte
ein beispiel an sprechen wir haben einen
bundesverfassungsschutz wir haben 16
landes verfassungsschutzämter mit
durchaus unterschiedlichen leistungs und
qualitäts unterschieden gerade die
kleineren bundesländer tun sich hier
schwer und der fall mecklenburg
vorpommern ist angesprochen worden wo
rechtswidrig und nachlässig gearbeitet
wurde und deswegen kommt es auch zu
unterschiedlichen zonen der sicherheit
in deutschland was nicht sein darf
deshalb möchte ich auch nochmal
ansprechen dass wir in der neuen
wahlperiode dieser bundestag uns mit den
ländern
gerade beim thema zusammenarbeit des
verfassungsschutzes zusammensetzen
müssen um etwa den vorschlag des
früheren innenministers thomas de
maizière aufzunehmen denn an seiner
aussage untersuchungsausschuss noch
einmal konkretisiert hat dass wir die
landesverfassung stärken müssen bzw
in einen gesamten
bundesverfassungsschutz geben müssen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und ja
wir müssen auch
die polizei und den verfassungsschutz
stärken sachlich personell das haben wir
zum großteil schon getan aber auch was
die technischen möglichkeiten angeht und
zukünftige anschläge effektiv verhindern
zu können
wir müssen die lehre aus dem
breitscheidplatz ziehen aber wir dürfen
diesen fall nicht eins zu eins als
blaupause nehmen für den nächsten
perfiden terroranschlag denn keiner von
uns weiß von wem wo war nun mit welchen
mitteln dieser anschlag geplant oder gar
ausgeführt wird und deswegen dürfen wir
liebe kollegen kollegen der grünen den
blick nicht verengen nur auf diese eine
fallkonstellation und sagen da wäre es
nicht notwendig gewesen auch sie müssen
bereit sein den nachrichtendiensten den
polizeien zusätzliche befugnisse zu
geben wir haben das vor kurzem beim
verfassungsschutz mit der quelle gemacht
und wir werden weiterhin für
online-durchsuchungen und der
speicherung von verkehrsdaten eintreten
und wir haben und wir haben und wir
haben auch nach wie vor eine hohe
gefährdungslage auch das hat der
verfassungsschutzbericht letzte woche
gezeigt 574 gefährder über 28.000
islamisten und deswegen müssen wir
schauen dass wir diese aus dem verkehr
ziehen und wenn wir sie nicht abschieben
können wenn wir sie nicht in strafhaft
abschiebehaft oder sicherungsverwahrung
nehmen können dann müssen wir sie so gut
wie möglich überwachen
denn wer sich selbst zum feind unserer
freiheitlichen lebensstil erbt er kann
keine nachsicht erwarten wir müssen
alles tun um derartige anschläge in
zukunft zu vermeiden
liebe gäste liebe angehörige ich danke
ihnen für ihr kommen es war uns eine
ehre sie hierzu haben alles gute für
sich suchen
herzlichen dank vielen dank alexander
throm
er sagt auch alexander tobias letzter
redner 450 die beweisaufnahme 1900
seiten bericht und der wird jetzt hier
nicht nur zur kenntnis genommen sondern
auch abgestimmt ausschuss empfiehlt den
bericht zur kenntnis zu nehmen wer
stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
dankeschön gegenprobe enthaltungen nicht
die beschlussempfehlung ist damit
einstimmig angenommen und damit zur
kenntnis genommen wobei es gibt sondern
wohnungen wie sie gehört haben von den
oppositionsfraktionen eine gemeinsame
sondervotum von fdp linken und bis 90
die grünen und auch ein sondervotum der
afg fraktion und die frage wie konnte es
dazu kommen warum konnte der schlimmste
islamistische terror anschlag in
deutschland nicht verhindert werden
obwohl der spätere attentäter den
sicherheitsbehörden bekannt war wurde
der wdr engmaschige überwacht noch
abgeschoben das fazit der fraktionen
nach diesem langen
untersuchungsausschuss fällt etwas
unterschiedlich auf und es wurde in der
debatte auch gesagt auf zu viele fragen
gibt es keine antwort